vous avez tous vos sens et énervé je
suis honnête ou sentimentales mon bilan
je suis bien
est-ce que vous avez une meuf pasqua
sur ce bel effet cette fois c'est vrai
faux chapeau vous sautez
c'est pas du tout du tout du tout en
ayant un sac à l'heure le chien est le
chien serveurs 45 est
ce que t mac et je suis mac est un mythe
ou va
l'amour réponse c cette nuit ont
franchement ça et cette nuit on va bien
longtemps mais contre une vraie question
c'est le temps c'est vrai avec le toit
était question s'est lâché sur l'amour
après je pars dans des cachettes us et
des cachets pour maigrir ah oui mais ça
me faisait megglé d'usinor j'ai grossi
il faut pas le faire des trucs là des
brûleurs de graisse ah ouais alors ça la
grèce elle pas oui elle par tüv aux
toilettes la grèce c'est par là sauf que
tu as plus direction je pense qu'il est
bien
brossés encore plus et je mens 2 je
mangeais des brûleurs de graisse
j'allais aux toilettes les plus grands
mangent et derrière sinon je pense que
c'est un truc organisé c'est un cercle
vicieux les brûleurs de graisse après
j'ai pris du bion 3 mois
c'est les problèmes des français ce que
je disais ah oui alors non mais moi je
jouis l'amour alors
je suis marié et été mariée on est
toujours à kayes jamais été mariés et tu
vois que ta femme oui
[Rires]
il a dit jeudi toujours avec sa femme il
a répondu oui comme
[Rires]
nous c'est quoi un oui d'ananas oui
quand vous posez oui mais vous ne
pourrez pas passer un week end vous êtes
toujours mariée mélenchon avait été mal
et non mais vous savez que vous avez une
wii
c'est ça avec ses vaches manque en fait
est ce qu ont posé la question est ce
que vous êtes heureux est ce que vous
êtes riche monsieur hanouna oui
[Musique]
[Rires]
en
fait c'est dingue j'ai vu la première
chose qui vient
mérites du coeur je prends la bravo
mathieu babaud tu vois là delphine
heureusement elle s'est elle fait même
genre elle même pour mes qualités le
point je vous coupe la parole oui je
suis énervé c'est le chien vous
appartient vous êtes d'abord demandé est
ce que vous êtes heureux que ça prenait
pas vous en foutez qu'on peut d'ailleurs
et vous est-ce que vous êtes toujours
avec la mère de vos enfants
vous poussez les forcer à paris bah oui
jours oui asie mais chaque jour avec
serai toujours avec un valaisan de coeur
mais oui toujours non mais ce que tu
habites survie non les habitants corps
avec elle mais oui non
question vous habitez toujours à kemer
de vos enfants oui
mais in situ oui effet l'enquêté
montrent vraiment
sinon nous
allons maintenant je suis heureux
franchement tempétueux mais ce que tu es
une meuf mais oui mais je vous ai dit
c'est à ma fille mais qu'à neuf que tu
as toujours oui oui mais que 76 connor
rencontre à la maternelle mois non non
non non mais tu es son père était petit
mais quand j'étais petit j'ai écrit vds
voulait tuer son père a même fait je
voulais tuer sa mère alors que tu étais
d'ailleurs j'ai embrasse moi on peut
avoir quelqu un d eux deux
c'est ton histoire de producteurs je dis
aux gens là là dans l'émission battle
n'est bien sûr m'énerve j'ai jamais fait
des arts des bdr il était calme oui oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
demandez moi si samedi joual en boîte
avoir exemple est-ce que samedi vous
allez sortir avec votre femme non
c'est banni vous étiez célibataire non
vous êtes avec une meuf oui mais c'est
votre mode de toujours oui mais ce sera
toujours un même de toujours ça marche
les enfants
à connaître depuis là aussi je connais
personne depuis la maternelle si
celui-ci a ramené le demain
des couples à sa fin bon bien sûr daniel
nous ramène pas quelqu'un
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]